Nous ne sommes pas morts dans le tremblement de terre près de notre respiration
Nous mourrons des maladies de la route et du cancer
Nous mourrons, surtout du cancer du poumon
Parce que ces substances provoquent différents cancers tels que
dangereux
Ils ont commencé à démolir des bâtiments fortement endommagés
Bien entendu, parmi ceux-ci
Il y a aussi des lieux de travail, tellement de produits chimiques
Il existe également des lieux de travail où l'on trouve des déchets, mais
en aucun cas
Sans prendre de précautions, il est actuellement gravement endommagé.
Ils ont déjà commencé à démolir les bâtiments
Comme vous pouvez le constater, en aucun cas
Il n'y a pas d'irrigation et la ville contient de la fumée
Il y a beaucoup d'étiquettes de la voiture
Nos enfants sont donc très perturbés.
Je veux dire, ils toussent beaucoup, nous aussi.
Nous nous sentons mal à l'aise
Bien
Chaque fois qu'un tout petit peu d'air s'échappe, c'est-à-dire à chaque fois
Sur le côté ça gonfle vers les maisons
je passe
[Musique]
sur les téléviseurs et les appareils électroménagers
métaux lourds dans les articles électroniques
jusqu'au mercure tu sais combien
que c'est nocif, des dommages directs au cerveau
C'est une substance qui donne
Les substances qui sont des métaux lourds sont également
peut être trouvé
[Musique]